the mass testing of an entire city
carried out by an army to bring
a deadly virus under control
this is liverpool the city's mayor is
joining volunteers
taking part in a project that could help
this city
and the country out of lockdown it's
important for the city that we
bring this virus back under control this
is a way of doing that it means that we
can identify asymptomatic people
people who have the virus and don't know
they've got it and it will actually
help the government from a national
perspective get on top of this as well
as it's rolled out across the uk
queuing up inside one of the six testing
sites is david sung
his swab can be turned around using a
lateral flow test
in about an hour without the need for a
lab
i think if the test is just as easy as
the experience i've had today
i don't see any real problems why people
shouldn't be
up for taking a test because they're all
you know the more information that
the people in control have the more they
can contain it and
view where it actually goes liverpool
has one of the highest coveted 19
infection rates in the country
identifying who is carrying the virus
can stop its spread this isn't the first
time the army has been called upon to
help with the national covert 19
effort there were the 19 gal hospitals
the distribution
of the ppe and now this the mass testing
that tells you everything you need to
know about the scale of the challenge
facing the country any operation this
size
needs the logistical expertise only the
army can bring
2 000 soldiers have been deployed here
moving up wednesday training on thursday
they've only been here 48 hours and here
we are friday lunchtime and the first
asymptomatic test centre
is open nothing like this has been done
in this country before
if it works a uk wide mass testing
strategy
could follow a significant step
in containing this virus ashish joshi
sky news
liverpool